I am concerned about it I don't like
hearing about it the US president reacts
to the news at prominent Saudi
journalist Jamal Khashoggi has been
killed and dismembered inside the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul other countries
too condemned the allegations some
summoning their Saudi ambassadors to
demand answers but what was going to be
the political fallout later that month
tens of top executives in media pulled
out of a prominent investment summit in
Riyadh but reportedly still sent lower
level representation Saudi Arabia has
billions of dollars of investment in
military deals with other countries
especially the United States three
billion dollars five hundred and thirty
three million dollars five hundred and
twenty five million dollars that's
peanuts for you this is a meeting
between the two men at the White House
earlier in the year Saudi Arabia and the
u.s. have been close allies for decades
and Donald Trump made it clear soon
after the killing that the billion
dollar deals would not be affected in
terms of the order of a hundred and ten
billion dollars think of that 110
billion dollars or all they're going to
do is give it to other countries and I
think that would be very foolish for our
country but there are other things we
can do that will be very severe
initially the Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman got a bit of the cold shoulder at
the g20 standing here on the far right
during the traditional family photo an
awkward moment captured Turkey's
president Reggie prepared one passing
the Crown Prince without as much as a
glance but over time despite the
international condemnation there were no
cut in diplomatic ties no major
sanctions the only independent
investigation carried out by the UN
Special Rapporteur for extrajudicial
summary and arbitrary executions Angus
Kalama we met her outside the consulate
during her visit
we have made a request to the Saudi
government for access to the consulate
as well as meeting with Saudis
authorities here and in Saudi Arabia we
are waiting for their response but she
was never given access and in June of
this year a damning conclusion 15 Saudi
state agent acting undercover of their
official status used state means to
execute mr. khashoggi it was overseen
plan and endorsed by eye level officials
and it was premeditated kalamaja was
called for an international
investigation and criticized the UN
Security Council for not doing enough to
act but at this year's g20 the family
photo telling perhaps the crown prince
center stage next to the US president
and the host Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a
a noticeable difference from the one
taken a month after kesaji was killed
and dismembered inside the Saudi
diplomatic mission a year on the
journalists body has never been found
but it seems that the world's leaders
have moved on and it's business as usual
Stephanie Decker of Jazeera